على مدار العام مشاهدينا لا تخلو الشهور
من المناسبات المختلفه مناسبات قد تكون
ثابته كاعياد الميلاد مثلا او متغيره
زيارات الاعراس غيرها طبعا لا ننسى هدايا
السفر التي يخصص لها الكثير منا مبلغا
خاصا مع باقي مصاريف الرحله اليوم في فقره
اقتصادك وبين الاختيارات والافكار
المتعدده نتحدث عن كيفيه تنسيق هذه
الهدايا ضمن ميزانيه معقوله ومن دون ان
نقصر في واجباتنا الاجتماعيه
مشاهدينا من دبي المستشار المالي والخبير
في التطوير المؤسسي عبد الله العطر اهلا
بك استاذ عبد الله معنا استاذ عبدالله
يعني هو هذا الوقت من السنه قبل الاجازه
الصيفيه يعني بنكون احنا سعيدين انه احنا
مقبلين وبنفس الوقت عطلانين الهم زي ما
بقولوا حاملين الهم انه الهدايا والاغراض
وكل ما يجب ان نحضره حتى نبدا هذه الاجازه
كيف بنقدر نختصر الهدايا اللي هم مش بس
مكلفين ومتعبين حتى نفكر بايش بدنا نجيب
نعم احنا لما نتكلم عن مفهوم الهديه جيد
راح نتكلم عن المعنى اللي تحمله المشكله
اليوم اللي نحن قاعدين نواجهها هي مو
مشكله ماديه بقدر ما هي مشكله ثقافيه اصبح
الناس يمثلون عواطفهم من خلال قيمه الهديه
يمثلون ايضا ذواتهم تمثيلا ماديا من خلال
الهديه فصار عند الشخص يقول لك انا انا
احبك اذا انا اشتري لك هديه بقيمه عاليه
الحين ان هذا المفهوم خاطئ خارج
المعنى الصحيح بمعنى الهديه الهديه مرتبطه
بالبساطه الهديه مرتبطه بالمعنى واحنا اول
مشكله عندنا هي مشكله ثقافيه لما يتعدل
هذا المفهوم ممتاز راح نلاحظ انه الموضوع
اصبح يعني اكثر رقابه هذه النقطه الاولى
النقطه الثانيه اليوم اصبحت الهديه مرتبطه
يعني في الفتره السابقه قبل مثلا 20 سنه
نقول قبل عقدين كان مرتبطه بمواسم
وفعاليات رئيسيه اليوم التلاقح الثقافي مع
الغرب وغيرها اصبح ووفد الينا في الوطن
العربي كثير من الفعاليات الجديده استاذ
عبد الله الاحتفال اتفضل يعني اذا سمحت
اول شيء صبحك الله بالخير اليوم احنا
عندنا المواجيب غير السفر هذه قاعد تكسر
الظهر بالنسبه لبعض الناس اذا رايحه يعني
صاحبك متزوج لازم تعطيه عانيه لانه متزوج
هذا صاحبك باحد ثاني جاله مولود ولد اخوك
ولد اختك الى اخره هذه كلها مصاريف قد لا
تكون في الحسبان لكن اليوم اصبحت واجب ان
انت تروح ما تقدر تروح عنده احد مشاي
وتدخل عليه شو تسوي شلون تقسمها
جيد الان مفهوم التكافل الاجتماعي واجب
علينا المجتمعات عربي صحيح النقطه
المرتبطه بالمعنى اليوم الفكره في العانيه
او في الهديه ليس في قيمتها في المعنى
الذي تحمله وفي الشيء المناسب لوضعك
المادي نحن اليوم صرنا صار عندنا تضارب ما
بين تمثيل الشخصيه من خلال قيمه الهديه
وما بين الاحراج اللي قد يتعرض لها الشخص
بسبب يعني افكار موجوده في داخله هو فقط
يقول لك شو بيقولوا عني الناس فهو قد يلجا
الى انه يحمل نفسه تكلفه اضافيه او عاليه
او لا تتناسب مع وضعه بحيث انه يشتري هديه
يوجه هديه للناس
في دقيقه بس يعني بطريقه عمليه
هديه هديه
ناخذها لاهلنا لما نروح نشوفهم في الاجازه
الصيفيه قديه المفروض تكون البادجت تبعتها
بحدود كم اكثر يعني بالدولار لو قلنا
جيد اولا هو لا يوجد قيمه محدده للعلم
والنقطه الاهم اليوم المغترب خارج بلده
الاصل في عودته لبلده انه هو الهديه مو
هديه للحكومه الله يسعدك اي والله الله
يسلمك لان اليوم كثير من كثير من
المغتربين صار يقول لك انا افضل اني ما
اتوجه لبلدي في الاجازه اروح مكان ثاني
لانه تكلفه الهديه هذه قاعده تحمله مصاريف
اضافيه كثير يعتقد بان الشخص موجود في
الغربه اذا هو قاعد على كلب من الذهب وهذا
الموضوع غير صحيح نحن يعني هذا دورك انت
اليوم لما ترجع لبلدك تصحح المفهوم يقول
له يا جماعه انا تغربت لكي اعمل ممتاز
واعيد افراد اسرتي في الامور الاساسيه
والله والله الشباب
المغتربين اللي ويانا حتى قاعد يقولون
قاعد يقول هذا اللقاء ينتشر بشكل واسع في
الوطن العربي حتى يفهم الاخر بانه احنا
جايين يلعب بلدنا لف نفسك بشريطه وروح عند
اهلك وان شاء الله يستقبلونك بالاحضان
شكرا المستشار المالي والخبير في التطوير
المؤسسي عبد الله العطر
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات